[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم دعا زعيم التيار الصدري
مقتدى الصدر دعا العراقيين الى اعلاء
صوتهم ضد الدكتاتوريه واتهم رئيس الوزراء
نور المالكي اتهمه بتكميم افواه معارضيه
وبافتراض
المالك في الوسط الشيعي وما حدوود كتلته
في الانتخابات العامه المرتقبه نهايه
الشهر
الحالي وهل توفر مواقف الصدر اساسا لتكوين
تحالفات جديده بين القوى العراقيه تغير
قواعد الممارسه السياسيه في
البلاد تاخذ اذا تصريحات مقتدى الصدر زعيم
التيار الصدري المنتقده لرئيس الوزراء نور
المالك وسياساته تاخذ اتجاها تصاعديا كما
يبدو مع اقتراب موعد الانتخابات العامه
نهايه الشهر الحالي لكنها تاتي وسط
انتقادات لاداء حكومه المالك من مكونات
عراقيه مختلفه اللافت ان تصريحات الصدر
المتواتره في الشهور الاخيره اذاء
التطورات في الساحه العراقيه تعطي مواقف
الرجل طابعا وطنيا يتجاوز الابعاد
المذهبيه
والقوميه ما الذي يفعله المالك في العراق
الانبار اصبحت تحت نيرانه منذ اربع اشهر
ولم تقتصر حملته العسكريه عليها وحسب بل
وصلت الى العاصمه بغداد ومحافظات اخرى وفي
هذا كله كان المكون السني مستهدفا على ما
يقول ساكن تلك المناطق
ومجرها لا يقول ذلك خصوم المالك السنه
وحسب بل اخرون دخل الرجل معهم في حرب
مفتوحه ومن بينهم مقتضى الصدر عليه اللعنه
المفسد عليه اللعنه من يسرق عليه اللعنه
من يوجه سلاحه ويجعله مقدمه للانتخابات
حتى ينتصر حبيبي لا يجب على السنه وعلى
الشيعه وعلى الاكراد وعلى كل الطوائف
الموجوده بالعراق تنتخب انا ادري هم
يريدون يهمش السنه حتى لا لا ينتخبون سووا
ب محافظاتهم قصف وارهاب وما ادري شنو حتى
لا ينتخبون لا صوت السنه سيعلو وصوت
الشيعه اعلى وصوت الاكراد هم يعلو ان شاء
الله تفكيك المالك ظاهره ونهجا في الحكم
هو ما يدعو اليه الصدر والانتخابات هي
السبيل فمن خلالها تنقذ البلاد من
الدكتاتوريه والعنف والحال هذه فان
المقاطعه تعني شيئا واحدا برايه وهو تحقيق
مسعى المالك بتحشيد ما يستطيعه من المكون
الشيعي خلفه عبر تخويفهم من مكونات الشعب
الاخرى واذا اضيف الى ذلك احتمال مقاطعه
قطاع من المكون السني للانتخابات فان
نتيجه الحتميه هي بقاء المالك في سده
الحكم ليس الصدر وحده من ينتقد وان كان
الاعلى صوتا والاكثر حده عمار الحكيم ايضا
ثمت خلافات بينه وبين المالك لم تعد خافيه
اخرها حول ملفي الحكومه المحليه في البصره
وتصريحات المالك عن الصدر حيث حذر من
المساس بمكانه الرجل
الدينيه المكون الكردي ايضا في قلب الخلاف
مع المالك على خلفيه الموازنه العامه
للدوله التي انسحبت كتله اسامه النجيفي من
اخر جلسه للبرلمان بسببها ووصل الامر
بمسعود البرزاني الى التهديد برد لا
تتوقعه بغداد فالخلاف برايه ليس حول
الموازنه ولا رواتب موظفي اقليم كردستان
التي جمدتها حكومه المالك بل حول هيبه
الاكراد انفسهم فماذا تبقى للملك اذا
عاشيه الانتخابات وخلافاته تستفحل مع
الجميع شيعه وسنه عربا
وكرداسه الدكتور سعد الحديثي ومن اربيل
الدكتور واثق الهاشمي رئيس
المجموعه العراقيه للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف ايضا من بغداد جواد
الشهيلي النائب في البرلمان العراقي عن
كتله الاحرار الصدريه وايضا عبر الهاتف من
محافظه واسط النائب في ائتلاف دوله
القانون قاسم الارجي نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا
وابدا معك استاذ جواد الشهيلي يعني هذا
الهجوم الشديد
لمقتضى الصدر على المالكي كيف يمكن
فهمه نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء
الخير عليكم جميعا انا اعتقد ان هذا
الهجوم ليس بالجديد مثل ما تقدم التقرير
انا اعتقد انه هو ليس بالهجوم لو صح
التعبير وانما هو تشخيص اخطاء وهناك اخطاء
حقيقيه حدثت بقياده الحكومه في الفتره
الاخيره وهذه لا يمكن السكون وبما ان
سماحه السيد القائد مقتضى الساد هو رجل
دين بالبدايه وابن عائله
حاربت الدكتاتوريه في ذلك الزمان لم
تستطيع ان تسكت على زمن ان يعود به
الدكتاتوريه مره اخرى لو صح التعبير كما
عبر عنها السيد مقتل الصدر لذلك نقول
بصراحه هناك اخطاء ارتكبها السيد المالكي
اخطاء كبيره كبيره جدا لا يمكن السكوت
عنها حربه لماذا تاخرت على على مثلا على
المليشيات المسلحه وع على داعش وعلى غيرها
الا قبيل الانتخابات لماذا تاخر في ان
يصرف القطع العراضي الىى المواطنين الى
قبيل الانتخابات لماذا استخدم موازنه
الدوله الكبيره لاجن الدعوه الانتخابيه
لماذا بدا يضرب في هذا الجانب ويضرب في
ذلك الجانب قبيل الانتخابات وانا اعتقد
وانا متاكد انه السيد المالكي يعول على
النفس الطائفي في سبيل الصعود لانه السيد
المالكي لا يستطيع ان ياخذ صوت واحدا لا
من الاكراد ولا من السنه فيعود ان يضرب
الاكراد ويضرب السنه في سبيل ان يسعد
السوق الانتخابي للسيد المالكي من الطرف
الشيعي هناك طرفين قيا من الطرف الشيعي
وهم السيد السيد مقتضى الصدر وكتلته
والسيد عمار الحكيم وكتلته بما انه اراد
اطاع هذين الطرفين الشيعيين يريد ان
يستحوذ على اكبر عدد ممكن ماذا يك ماذا
يكمن في راس السيد المالكي انا اقول طيب
ماذا يكمن في راس السيد المالكي خلينا
خلينا نطرح هذا السؤال على قاسم الاعرجي
ماذا براس نوري المالكي ماذا يفعل بالعراق
لماذا يفعل كل ذلك عندما نستمع الى هذه
الاتهامات التي ووجهها مقتضى الصدر لنور
المالكي لماذا يفعل كل هذا
بالعراق بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكم
وللضيوف الكرام حقيقه انا استغرب ان يقال
ان في العراق هنالك دكتاتوريه وان كان
حاليا الحكم في العراق دكتاتوريه فماذا
نسمي نظام صدام سابقا القاعده وداعش حقيقه
موجوده على الارض ولا يستطيع احد ان ينكر
ان دوله العراق اللا اسلاميه الان معلنه
في الفلو وروايات ترفع ويعلنون عن انفسهم
والتصوير المشاهد الفيديو التي يعرضونها
يوميا ويقومون بقتل الجيش العراقي فكيف
يكون القتال في الانبار هو مع اهل السنه
وانما القتال هو مع تنظيم القاعده اهل
السنه والاكراد والشيعه ابناء هذا البلد
ولا احد يستطيع ان يهمش هؤلاء جميعا نعم
هنالك خلافات سياسيه بين كتل ونحن في فتره
الدعايا الانتخابيه ممكن في كل جهه تفسر
هذا الخطا والطرف الاخر لا يعت اعتقد بخطا
هذا الموقف غياب الحوار والجلوس على
الطاوله الواحده وبالتاكيد سبب في كثير من
هذه الخلافات او توسع الخلافات ما بين
الاطراف واعتقد ان لكل كتله لديها ناخبيها
ولديها جمهورها واعتقد هذه المواقف لا
تؤثر على الناخبين ولا تؤثر على الكتل
البرلمانيه في الانتخابات المقبله اها لكن
لكن يعني مقتضى الصدر وجه نصيحه لنور
المالكي وقال له يعني بما معناه خدمت
العراق بما يكفي لتنصرف وياتي اخرون
يخدمون العراق ليس في العراق الا نوري
المالكي لا يوجد هنالك من يقول ان السيد
المالكي لابد ان ياخذ الولايه الثالثه
نتائج الانتخابات وطبيعه التحالفات
المقبله هي التي تحدد من هو رئيس الوزراء
وان كانت كتله السيد المالكي هي الاولى
بالتاكيد سوف تكون حضوره اكبر واذا كانت
هنالك كتل اخرى استطاعت ان تاتي ب اصوات
داخل البرلمان بمقاعد اكثر من كتله السيد
المالكي من الممكن ان تجري تحالفات لا
ممكن لا احد اليوم يتكهن من هو رئيس وزراء
العراق القادم وانما نتائج الانتخابات
وطبيعه التحالفات هي التي تحدد ذلك طيب
استاذ سعد الحديثي يعني استمعت لما قاله
قاسم الاعرجي حكم المالكي ليس حكم
دكتاتوري هو حكم ديمقراطي الرجل يحاول ان
يحكم بما لديه من خبره
سياسيه
هل يعني ما رايك بهذا
الكلام يعني في الحقيقه هنالك وجهات نظر
مختلفه بهذا الصدد قوى كثيره تعتبر على
الاقل في ائتلاف رئيس الوزراء تعتبر انه
منهج رئيس الوزراء منهج قائم على احترام
دستور والتعامل مع الياته بصوره موضوعيه
وهو يطبق الصلاحيات التي اعطاه اياها او
منحه اياها الدستور لكن بالمقابل هناك كتل
اخرى تتحدث عن تفرد في اداره القرار عن
ابعاد وتهميش للقوه والسياسيه الشريكه في
في الحكومه كانت هذه الاتهامات توجه على
نطاق القائمه العراقيه منذ بدايه العمليه
السياسيه او منذ تولي السيد رئيس الوزراء
ولايته الثانيه وربما حتى الاولى لكن
شهدنا خلال العامين الاخيرين ان هناك
اطراف انضمت الى القائمه العراقيه في
موقفها تجاه سياسه رئيس الوزراء واليه
ادارته ل القرار السياسي في هذا البلد
وبدا هذا الامر بالتحالف الكردستاني ثم
توسع لينضم او لتنظم قوى جديده من داخل
التحالف الوطني في التاف الوطني تحديدا
التيار الصدري ثم بعده التحق المجلس
الاعلى هنالك انتقادات اصبحت واضحه ومعلن
وتتكرر باستمرار لاداء وسياسه رئيس
الوزراء من قبل هذه القوى نعم ولكن نعم
لكن سيد حديث يعني في النهايه هذه ال
الاتهامات
والادانه من الصدر لاداء المالكي ماذا
يكون الهدف منها الان في هذا الوقت بالذات
خصوصا ان مقتدى الصدر كان قد قال في وقت
مضى انه لا يمكن ازاحه نوري المالكي لانه
موجود بتوافق امريكي بريطاني ايراني هل
تغير مثلا هذا التوافق اليوم كي يطلق
الرجل هذه الاتهامات من جديد اولا
ب يعني باعتقادي الاتهامات بين الرجلين
بين رئيس الوزراء وبين زعيم التيار صدري
ربما متكرره و متصاعده في الاونه الاخيره
ولا استبعد ان تكون ان يكون هذا التصاعد
مرتبطا بقرب موعد الانتخابات وفي اطار
الحملات الانتخابيه او الحمه الانتخابيه
التي بدات في العراق منذ اشهر ربما بدات
قبل ثلاثه اشهر او اكثر لكن الامر المؤكد
انه زعيم تيار الصدري اشار في ما حدث
بالنسبه لتشكيل الحكومه السابقه نتيجه
توافق امريكي ايراني هذا امر يعرفه الجميع
وتمت صفقه سياسيه انتجت الحكومه الحاليه
التي اوشكت ولايتها على النهايه بشكلها
الحالي وبرئاسة
وهذا هذه الحملات على الاقل بالنسبه لزعيم
التيار الصدي تجاه رئيس الوزراء هي في
محاوله لحث الناخبين على انتخاب شخصيات او
قوى سياسيه اخرى في محاوله لتاثير على على
نتائج الانتخابات استباق الانتخابات وفي
نفس الوقت ربما محاوله لضغط على الجانب
الايراني على اعتبار انه الجانب الاكثر
تاثيرا في المعادله السياسيه في العراق
وفي تشكيل التحالفات على الاقل داخل
التحالف الوطني ربما الموقف الايراني حتى
اللحظه لم يتبلور ولهذا نشهد تصاعدا في
الاتهامات المتبادله في محاوله التاثير
على الموقف الايراني باتجاه القوى التي
سوف
بكل نقطه الى الاستاذ واثق الهاشمي هل هل
فيما ذكر محاوله ربما للتاثير على الموقف
الايراني الذي يبدو غير واضح حتى
الان قبيل الانتخابات شكرا مساء الخير انا
اهلا بك نعم شكرا مساء الخير انا اعتقد
الدول لها مصالح اللاعب الايراني واللاعب
الامريكي هم الاقوى والابرز في العراق ومن
يكون رئيس الوزراء عليه احضا بتاييد
الدولتين معا وليس احدى الدول في حاله
فقدان احت الدولتين السف لن يكون هناك
رئيس الوزراء لكن ودي ان احدث عن قضيه
الان بدات حمله انتخابيه مستعره تعمل على
مبدا التصريحات القويه الضرب تحت الحزام
لكل الاطراف الموجودين اذكر ان هذا المشهد
نفسه كان موجود في 2010 بالنسبه الى كته
التيار الاحرار كانت تقول انها ك خط احمر
على المالكي لا يكون رئيسا لوزراء العراق
وكان هناك مرشح هو السيد الجعفري ثم السيد
عادل عبد المهدي لكن بضغط خارجي رفع هذا
الخط الاحمر وتحول الى خط اخضر بعد تشكيل
الحكومه دب الصراع في داخل البيت الشيعي
انا اعتقد هذا المشهد سنشهد في المرحله
المقبله البيت الشيعي فيه صراع كبير البيت
السني فيه صراع كبير بين الكتل الموجوده
وكذلك البيت الكردي فلذلك بعد قبل
الانتخابات ستكون هناك عوامل خارجيه تضبط
باتجاه اعاده ثلاثه كتل شيعيه وسنيه
وكرديه تتوافق في حكومه تكون حكومه شراكه
وطنيه يقدم فيها رئيس الوزراء المقبل
تنازلات كبيره جدا لكن بعد اعلان الحكومه
سنعود مره اخرى للمربع الاول في قضيه
التشهير والتسقيط سؤالي اناي كمراقب اذا
كان السيد المالك لا يصلح الحكم او السيد
اسيمه النجيفي لا يصلح رئيس البرلمان
لماذا لا نطبق الاليات الدستوريه بسحب
الثقه من الحكومه لماذا لا نطبق الديات
الدستوريه بسحب وحل البرلمان والدعوه
لانتخابات جديده انا اعتقد هذه كلها دعايه
انتخابيه للتاثير على جمهور محدود لا يمكن
للسيد المالكي ان يحظى بصوتا سنيا واحدا
ولا يمكن للسيد النجيفي ان يحظى بصوتا
شيعيا واحدا وهذه الحاله معكوسه بالجانب
الكردي لذلك كل من هذه الاطراف تحاول ان
تؤثر على جمهورها الشيعي الشيعي والسن
السن والكرد الكردي وهذه مشكله في المشهد
العراقي المعقد الذي يرغب الجميع في تبوء
السلطه لمراحل مقبله واذكر ان مجلس
الوزراء العراقي لديه صوت واحد للسيد
المالكي وكل الوزراء الموجودين من الاحرار
المعارضه و متحدون والاكراد كانوا يصوتوا
بنعم مع المالكي في كثير من القرارات
والقوانين التي تصدر وترحل الى مجلس
النواب طيب يعني سنناقش هذه النقطه مساله
الدعايه الانتخابيه والتوقيت مغزى هذا
التوقيت لكن بعد ف فاصل قصير كما قلت
سنناقش بعده امكانيه تكوين تحالفات جديده
ايضا بين القوى العراقيه تغير من قواعد
الممارسه السياسيه في البلاد بعد انتقادات
زعيم التيار الصدري لرئيس الوزراء نوري
المالكي مشاهدينا سوف نعود لا تذهبوا
بعيدا
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش ابعاد اتهام زعيم
التيار الصدري لرئيس الوزراء العراقي نور
المالكي بافتعال حرب في مناطق السنه
لتهميش اتحول الى الاستاذ جواد الشهيلي
كنا نتحدث عن مغزى التوقيت وهل هي قصه
دعايه انتخابيه صراع على الصوت الشيعي
ربما المقتضى الصدر يحاول ان يطرح نفسه ك
بديل والضرب في المنيان في المالكه هو
الاقرب يعني كسب الصوت
الشيعي انا اعتقد انه بالتوقيتات الزمنيه
الجميع يحسن اكثر من واجه السيد المالكي
هو سمحت سيد مقتضى الصدر اكثر من انتقد
المالكي وسمح السيد مقتضى الصدر هل كانت
قبل شهر هل كانت قبل شهرين هل كانت قبل
سنه انا اعتقد سماحه السيد انكال في ولم
يتوانى في الهجوم بحق طبعا على رئاسه
الوزراء وعلى رئيس الوزراء بسبب قله
الخدمات وبسبب قله الامن وبسبب ضعف كل شيء
مقدم من قبل هذه الحكومه منذ زمن طويل اما
الان انا اعتقد انه سماحه السيد مقتضى
الصدر الجميع يعرف انه انسحب من الوضع
السياسي لكن تكليفه الشرعي كما قاله يوم
امس في لقاء او مؤتمر الصحفي الذي كنا
نحضره معنا مع الشيخ صباح انا والشيخ صباح
وسمح السيد الذي كان يدافع به عن صوت
الحاق وصوت المظلوم وصوت مكافحه الفساد هو
قال قالها نص انا تكليف الشرعي وتكليف
الانساني لن يسمح لي بالسكوت ومنذ زمن
طويل انا لن اسكت لذلك سمحت سيد لا يريد
ان يرشح لرئاسه الوزراء وكتله الاحرار
بدات بالتصاعد يوما بعد يوم ولا نحتاج
لضرب الاخرين في سبيل ان نحصل على مقاعد
اخرى انا اعتقد انه هنا وصلنا الى مرحله
اللا عوده عودا على ب كما قال السيد
العرجي قبل قليل قال انه لو حصل على اصوات
اكبر هذه هذا الكلام يغرون به بعض الناس
البسطاء انا اعتقد هو يفهم وانا افهم بدون
كتله نيابيه اكبر لن تتحقق الحكومه وبدون
اغلبيه لن يصوت على رئيس الجمهوريه ورئيس
الوزراء لذلك نعتقد الجميع بحاجه بحاجه
الى كتله نيابيه اكبر واليوم العراق انا
اعتقد بعد الازمه التي مرت به قد يعبر
الطائفه وقد يعبر المكون المعين وقد تكون
هناك كتله نيابيه اكبر حتى من من ان تكون
سنيه او شيعيه و وقد تكون مكونه من
الاكراد والسنه والشيعه لتشكيل الحكومه
بعيدا عن السيد المال
كل الكتل السياسيه من الان انا اعطيك
واعده علي مننا الى بعد انتهاء الانتخابات
لم تسمح بعوده السيد المالكي مره اخرى
يعني اذا يتحدثون انه وصلت واحد في مجلس
الوزراء يقوللي هو من القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه ومن هو اللي كان يصرف
بالموازنه قرارات مجلس النواب نعتقد انه
يجب ان يكون الخطاب متوازن ما بين انه
خدمه الشارع العراقي التي اندثرت من زمان
الامن الذي اندثر من زمان بعض المحسوبين
على رئيس الوزراء سرقه اكبر عدد ممكن من
من الاستثمارات ومن طيب كل هذه النقاط
تحتاج ردا من الاستاذ قاسم الاعرجي كيف
ترد على ما قاله استاذ شهيلي
الان بالتاكيد نتائج الانتخابات واقول
طبيعه التحالفات يا اخي الشهيلي طبيعه
التحالفات المقبله هي التي سوف تحدد شكل
الحكومه المقبله نعم لابد من وجود كل
مكونات الشعب العراقي في حكومه الاغلبيه
السياسيه القادمه الان حكومه الشراكه
كيف كل الشركاء
السياسيين السياسه لا توجد فيها ممنوعات
في نتائج الانتخابات والظروف هي التي تحكم
مثل ما كان التيار الصدري وغيرهم كان
معارضين لوجود السيد المالكي للولايه
الثانيه وبالتالي اصبح رئيسا للوزراء
بالتاكيد هنالك مساعي حثيثه و هنالك من
يعمل من اجل لملمه الوضع العراقي ما ممكن
ان يبقى العراق مقسما بهذه الطريقه اليوم
لا توجد هنالك ازمات مفتعله اليوم مجلس
الوزراء مكون هنالك وزراء للتيار الصدي
يوقعون على الموازنه فكيف ان السيد المالك
ويتصرف الموازن لمفرد وزراء الكرد وزراء
القائمه العراقيه نعم هو رئيس الوزراء هو
القائد العام القوات المسلحه الدستور هو
الذي اعطا قال هو القائد العام القوات
المسلحه هل من السيد المالكي لا زم
بالماده السابعه ثانيا الذي تلزمه بقتال
الارهاب وان لا يكون العراق مقر للارهاب
لماذا القتال ضد القاعده وداعش يعتبر قتال
ضد اهل السنه من يقول ان القاعده هم اهل
السنه من يقول ان لابد ان لا نحاسب مفسدين
يجب علينا ان نحاسب مفسدين وهو السيد
الشهيلي من الناشطين في لجنه النزار دكتور
دكتور صاد حديثي نعم في الدقاقه الاخيره
دكتور سعد الحديثي يعني ما هي سبل الخروج
بالعراق اليوم من هذا الوضع الذي يحذر
كثيرون من انه قد ينزلق الى حرب طائفيه لا
قدر
الله يعني في اعتقادي في ظل المعطيات
السياسيه المتوفره على الارض والسياسه
تتعاطى مع الممكن ولا تتعاطى مع ما ينبغي
ان يكون اعتقد ربما السبيل الاوحد لاخراج
العراق من دوامه الازمات والاضطراب الامني
وتهديد وحدته واستقراره وسلمه الاهلين
وتماسك نسيجه الاجتماعي يتم بانتاج كتل
عابره للانتماء الاثنيه هنالك بوابه امل
ربما فتحت او نافذه امل فتحت امام
العراقيين وهو اعاده تشكيل التحالفات
البرلمانيه بعد الانتخابات لانه لا اهميه
في الحقيقه لمن يفوز بالمرتبه الاولى في
الانتخابات في الانتخابات السابقه فازت
القائمه العراقيه بالمرتبه الاولى لكنها
لم تشكل حكومه نتحدث عن تحالفات انتخابيه
او تحالفات برلمانيه تاتي بعد الانتخابات
وعن معادله اقليميه عن موقف اقليمي يعني
هل القطيعه مثلا اليوم بين التيار الصدري
وائتلاف دوله القانون ائتلاف رئيس الوزراء
وصلت الى حد نهائي لا يمكن العوده عنه ام
يمكن لطهران ان تلعب الدور الذي لعبته
قبيل تشكيل الحكومه السابقه في اعاده
ترميم العلاقه بينهما وتجسير الهو هذا امر
في الحقيقه لا يمكن الاجابه عليه بصوره
قاطعه لكن الامر المؤكد ان هناك مناخ
ملائم اليوم لانشاء تحالفات عبر
الانتماءات الاثنيه تجسد هذا الامر في
تشكيل حكومات محليه عقب الانتخابات
المحليه الاخيره في محافظه بغداد وفي
محافظه دياله انتجت كسرا للتحالفات
الاثنيه التي كانت قائمه على اساس
الانتماء الطائفي او العرقي اعتقد هذا هو
ربما يكون النافذه الوحيده التي يمكن
للعراق ان ينطل من خلالها على على الامل
وعلى على رحبه الاستقرار والسلم الاهلي في
المستقبل القريب اما اذا كفات القوى
السياسيه من جديد لتتح الف وتتكتل على اسس
اثنيه انا اقول ان العراق سائر الى الى
المجهول ومصيره لن يكون افضل حالا
بالتاكيد من مصيره اليوم باعتباره دوله
فاشله تعاني من ازمات ومشاكل امنيه
وسياسيه واضطرابات مستمره استاذ واثق
الهاشمي انت كيف ترى
الحل يعني انا اعتقد الحل نعم اذا كنا
نستطيع ان نحقق موضوعه الاغلبيه السياسيه
مع وجود معارضه في البرلمان سنكون في دكه
الامان لكن انا اعتقد واقع الحال الجميع
يتصارع على السلطه الجميع يتصارع على
المناصب كل ما نسمع انا اعتقد جعجع
اعلاميه واقع الحال الضاغط الخارجي سيكون
كبيرا لاعاده هذه المكونات مره اخرى
وبالتالي تشكل حكومه اغلبيه صعبه تحقق
انجازات على المستوى القريب مع وجود خطر
كبير جدا هو حجم المقاطعه الانتخابيه اذا
استمر الحل على هذا المنوال سوف لن يشارك
سوى جمهور الاحزاب المشتركه في هذا الصراع
اما الجمهور الاكبر كما حدث في مجالس
المحافظات لن يشترك في الحكومه وت بالتالي
ستكون رسالته مؤثره وبالغه الى الجميع في
مقاطعه الانتخابات نعم ولكن الرسائل التي
يرسلها نوري المالكي ليست هذه التي تتحدث
عنها رسائل
يعني يريد ان يقول من ورائها انه رئيس
الوزراء القادم والشعب هو الذي
يريدني انا اقول وفق الاستطلاعات وفق
المعلومات ان السيد المالكي سيحظى بولايه
ثالثه للمرحله المقبله لاسباب هناك رغبه
دوليه وتوافق دولي عليه وهناك جمو ال في
كتله دوله القانون وقد يكون هناك الجمهور
مع كتل اخرى سيدعم لتشكيل كتله اكبر عددا
في المرحله المقبله الا اذا حدثت امور
اخرى لكن انا اعتقد هذه الحكومه ايضا
وذهاب السيد المالكي الى دوره ثالثه
سيواجه صعوبات بالغه جدا في تشكيل الحكومه
قد تستغرق فقره طويله ولا يوجد مرشحين
اخرين بارزين على السطح لحد هذه اللحظه
جواد الشهيلي ترجيح دوره ثالثه ولايه
ثالثه للمالكي ما رايك يعني انا اعتقد
اعتقد السيد الهاشمي يتحدث وكانما العراق
لم ود ان السيد المالكي ونرجع الى زمن
صدام هذا غير مقبول وغير مقنع وانا اعتقد
اذا كان يعتقدون بوجود ضغوطات سياسيه من
الخارج فهم منقادون هم لا ينقادون ال
العراق ينقادون الى دول الخارج مستحيل ان
تكون دوله ثالثه للمالكي معناتها ان لا
يكون سنه في العراق معناته ان لا يكون
اكراد في العراق معناته ان لا يكون لا
تيار صدري ولا مجلس اعلى في العراق ومن
يحكم يحكم المالكي بحزب الدعوه ودوله
القانون لا صح التعبير وهذا ضرب من ضرب
الخيال اعتقد ان السيد الهاشمي يكذب نفسه
مره ويكذب على الشعب العراقي مره ثانيه مع
الاس نشكر ضيوفنا جميعا اشكرك الاستاذ
جواد
الشهيلي واشكر ايضا الاستاذ قاسم الاعرجي
كنتم معنا عبر الهاتف نشكر ايضا الدكتور
سعد الحديثي كنت معنا من بغداد والاستاذ
واثق الهاشمي كنت معنا من اربيل بهذا ناتي
مشاهدينا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر ونلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا اط
بالمى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء